andrew cuomo runs into the me too buzz
saw trump returns at cpac
and the next superman reboot will be
written by a guy who thinks america is
systemically racist i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with vpn so should you
visit expressvpn.com
ben alright we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first reminder we are
now at the mercy of one party control
an agenda driven by tax and spend
economics
we will get into the social
ramifications of course but fiscally you
can expect compounded growth of the
national debt
and eventually the systemic devaluation
of the us dollar so you need to
diversify out of cash cash is not the
best place to hold your assets
and you want to make sure that you're
not in something completely volatile you
want to be diversified
out of stocks because yeah stocks are
great but you want to make sure you have
some money
in an asset that has never been worth
zero i'm talking of course about
precious metals this is why you need to
talk to my friends
over at birch gold group birch gold
group will help you diversify a portion
of your savings an ira or eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
they are the premier precious metals ira
company in america with an a-plus better
business bureau rating countless
five-star reviews and thousands of
satisfied customers
there is a tidal wave of inflation
coming gold would be your hedge text ben
to 47 47 47 for your free information
kit on precious metals high array or to
speak with the birch gold representative
today
time is running out but you can protect
your savings right now text ben
247-4747 again that is text my name ben
247-47-47 ask all of your questions to
my friends at birch gold get your
answers and diversify into precious
metals now text ben
247 47 47. all right so andrew cuomo is
now in real trouble all it took
was the election let's be frank about
this if it had not been
for donald trump losing the election
andrew cuomo would still be riding
high in new york because the media
decided for months and months and months
that we're not going to cover any bad
allegations about andrew cuomo we knew
as early as may of last year that andrew
cuomo was covering up nursing home
deaths
and all of the people who are now coming
forward and suggesting that andrew cuomo
sexually harassed them
or sexually assaulted them in some way
all of those people knew what they knew
last year now i don't know whether them
coming out is political
what i do know is that the media's
interest in these sorts of stories only
started to crop up
bizarrely around the time of the
election it was really only after
really after the inauguration then it
was like the media they said oh you know
we don't need this cuomo guy anymore
right before we needed this cuomo guy
because he was
going to be kept in contrast with the
trumpy horrible republicans
and this is why they always drew this
sort of good angel bad angel on your
shoulder routine where the good angel
for some odd reason was andrew cuomo the
evil angel was ron de santa saying
things like
freedom and go back to school and you
have andrew cuomo being
no we should never go back to school and
it was like no you you should you should
100 go back to school you should 100
have some freedoms you should have your
business open but andrew cuomo was hero
of the day well now
all of it is coming apart and it's
coming apart awful fast for andrew cuomo
because here's the thing
revolutionaries don't have friends they
just have tools and andrew cuomo was a
tool
and he's still a tool but a different
kind of tool now so
here is the the latest from the uk sun
new york governor andrew cuomo branded
as a monster as
democrats demand inquiry after sex pest
allegations by second staffer
according to the uk son other leading
democrat women have turned on the new
york
governor and demanded an inquiry into
the abhorrent and heartbreaking
allegations
cuomo who denies wrongdoing said he had
been asked that he had asked clinton
appointed federal judge barbara jones to
examine claims by two ex-staffers
originally he said
you know what why don't we have like a
an internal investigation
and we'll have some of my friends do an
investigation and people are like nah
that's not gonna work and he released a
statement saying
these things you know i deny them but we
should have an investigation
then he released a second statement that
was the the chain of events over the
course of the weekend
last night charlotte bennett 25 claimed
her 63 year old boss
quizzed her about her sex life after she
went to him for help as a survivor of
sexual assault
which is um very not good she told the
new york times cuomo asked her if she
was monogamous in her relationships and
if she had ever had sex with older men
first of all i will never to the day i
die understand
some of the mating habits of the typical
american male i just won't
like how many scandals have you seen
where guys will send pictures of their
genitals to women
in the somehow mistaken belief that this
is attractive to women like has this
line never worked
has andrew cuomo's line of work has ever
walked up to like a 20 year old girl and
been like
you know what darling you ever have sex
with older men
it's just it's just the guy from
airplane asking
young boys where they like gladiator
movies apparently she said i understood
that the governor wanted to sleep with
me and felt horribly uncomfortable and
scared
and was wondering how i was going to get
out of it and assumed it was the end of
my job
charlotte's claims came three days after
another ex-aide lindsay boylan
claimed cuomo kissed her on the lips and
suggested that they play strip
poker senior new york democrats remain
tight-lipped after the first round of
allegations on wednesday last night
cuomo was dealt a crushing blow and his
own deputy and other members of his
party appeared to turn their backs on
him which you knew was coming right he
is no longer useful to the party
this is the political calculation for
democrats is the person useful enough
that you keep them in office knowing
that they did all these bad things
right al franken was not useful enough
so al franken went away the dodo bird
but
andrew cuomo was kind of useful so we
sort of ignored all the stuff ted
kennedy was useful for decades so they
kept propping them up bill clinton was
useful until he was no longer useful
and that's that's andrew cuomo he was
now lieutenant governor kathy hokel
called for an independent review into
the allegations saying quote everyone
deserves to have their voice heard and
taken seriously
remember that lady who alleged that joe
biden had sexually assaulted her
yeah you haven't heard about her in a
while have you because joe biden's still
useful
i guarantee you that if joe biden had
lost the election
those allegations would be coming back
up right now senate leader andrea
stewart cousins called the new
allegations deeply disturbing and
concerning
she said the behavior has no place in
the workplace she also echoed calls by
republicans for the ag to take over the
probe
this of course letitia james who has
decided to unleash the beast on andrew
cuomo right she's the person who came
out earlier this year
and said hey by the way weren't you
covering up those nursing home numbers
leticia james it it'd be hard for me to
imagine she does not have her eye
on the new york governor spot because
the new york ag very often has their eye
on the new york governor's spot
new york city mayoral candidate my wiley
said i'm disgusted i believe charlotte
bennett
it's always fun when democrats are held
to account by their own standards
right this is the way that this works
when they say believe all women and then
a woman comes forward alleging something
about a democrat
then they have to either pretend the
woman doesn't exist or they have to
believe all women
now if the person's useful they pretend
the woman doesn't exist right tara reid
just doesn't exist but
if the woman is is of use then they will
say
that she ought to be believed according
to maya wiley senior officials in the
governor's office were aware of his
behavior what happened to these
complaints
why was no further action taken how many
other times has this happened
state senator alessandro biaggi tweeted
bluntly new york governor cuomo you're a
monster it is time for you to go
right now and now again some of this has
to do
with the new york democrats just not
liking andrew cuomo he's a very
unpopular figure with fellow new york
democrats he treats them
with disdain he because his father was a
very very popular
guy in new york marriott people he's
able to live off the back of that but
nobody actually likes andrew cuomo if
you talk to any politician democrat or
republican in new york they think he's a
bully and a braggart and a jackass
everyone in new york thinks this if
you're in new york politics so now they
finally have their shot
and they're going to take it now here is
my standard due process right it's the
same standard that i held for
brett kavanaugh i hold it for joe biden
as well hold it for donald trump
there's a due process of law you bring
evidence of these allegations whatever
evidence you have to back them up
and then we have to adjudicate whether
we think that these events actually
happened as stated or not
right that is the that is how these
things work but andrew cuomo didn't hold
that standard he said that there was
enough evidence that brett kavanaugh had
done something wrong that his name
should be withdrawn from supreme court
nomination
so he didn't get to claim due process at
this point the standard is what the
standard is
and whatever standard you hold that is
what's going to come right around on you
through the power of scheidenfrida
fellow state senator todd kaminski a
former federal prosecutor said this
pattern of behavior requires a swift and
immediate independent investigation
the leader of which must be empowered to
access all of the evidence
ms biagi is chair of the ethics and
governance committee she said she was
speaking out as a new yorker and a
survivor of special
sexual abuse and she added i commend the
courage of miss bennett and lindsay
boylan
for coming forward okay so the first
statement from governor andrew cuomo
we'll get to
in just one second first a lot is
happening at your front door these days
a lot of packages being dripped uh
dropped off you have doordash a lot of
stuff happening in that front door
you need to make sure you know what's
going on on your property and this is
why i have
ring.com what happens at our front door
my kids are constantly running out the
front door gotta make sure that they're
not running into the street
ring.com makes me aware when this is
happening that's why
it's the perfect time to upgrade your
doorstep with a ring video doorbell with
ring
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door from anywhere right on your
phone you're never gonna miss a visitor
whether it's your neighbor your dinner
your groceries or your kids
and keep those packages and deliveries
safe with motion detection you get
notified even if they don't even ring
the doorbell this is a super useful
thing
i love having that ring video doorbell
i've actually added some ring security
cameras
around the house as well because i want
to make sure that my entire property
is blanketed with a layer of security no
matter your home ring has everything you
need to protect it see and speak to
whoever is at that door from anywhere
with video doorbells
keep an eye on every corner of your
house with easy to install indoor and
outdoor
cams protect your whole home with ring
alarm it's a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself right now get a
special offer on the ring welcome kit at
ring.com
it comes with that ring of video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro it is the
perfect way to upgrade your front door
and start that ring video experience go
to ring.com
again that's ring.com alrighty so
andrew cuomo has now put out a couple of
statements
so his first statement said this miss
bennett was a hard-working and valued
member of our team during covet she has
every right to speak out
when she came to me and opened up about
being a sexual assault survivor and how
it shaped her
and her ongoing efforts to create an
organization that empowered her voice to
help other survivors
i tried to be supportive and helpful
miss bennett's initial impression was
right i was trying to be a mentor to her
i never made advances toward miss
bennett nor did i ever intend to act in
any way that was inappropriate the last
thing i would ever have wanted was to
make her feel any of the things that are
being reported
the situation cannot and should not be
resolved in the press i believe the best
way to get to the truth is through a
full and thorough
outside review i'm directing all state
employees to comply with that effort
i ask all new yorkers to await the
findings of the reviews they know the
facts before making any judgments
i will have no further comment until
after the review has concluded
okay well there's only one problem with
that um then he says writes a no further
statements until after their view has
been concluded
within 24 hours there is a further
statement from magic
oh man politics comes at you fast here
was his second statement this one from
andrew cuomo
questions have been raised about some of
my past interactions with people in the
office
i never intended to offend anyone or
cause any harm now what do we know from
the left
intent doesn't matter right we now live
in the world of the left where intent
does not matter all that matters is how
people were impacted by your words
governor
so in keeping with the standards created
by your own side of the political aisle
it's time to go
he said i spend most of my life at work
and colleagues are often also personal
friends
at some at work sometimes i think i'm
being playful and make jokes that i
think are funny
i do on occasion tease people in what i
think is a good natured way i do it in
public and in private you've seen me do
it at briefings hundreds of times
i've teased people about their personal
lives their relationships about getting
married or not getting married
i mean no offense and only attempt to
add some levity and banter it's what is
a very serious business
i now understand that my interactions
may have been insensitive or too
personal
and that some of my comments given my
position made others feel in ways i
never intended i acknowledge some of the
things i have said have been
misinterpreted as an unwanted flirtation
to the extent anyone felt that way i am
truly sorry
about that to be clear i never
inappropriately touched anybody and i
never propositioned anybody and i never
intended to make anybody feel
uncomfortable but these are allegations
new yorkers deserve answers to
that is why i've asked for outside
independent review that looks at these
allegations
separately my office has heard
anecdotally that some people have
reached out to mrs bennett to express
displeasure about her coming forward
my message to anyone doing that is you
have misjudged what matters to me in my
administration you should stop now
period okay so does andrew cuomo survive
all of this
well it depends on who thinks andrew
cuomo is useful because in politics
again
truth and falsity don't matter the only
thing that matters is are you useful
so jen sackey came out she said you know
joe biden he supports that
andrew cuomo's idea for an independent
review here's the very refreshing
very honest jen sackey spokeswoman for
president biden
president biden has been consistent that
he believes that
every woman should be heard should be
treated with respect and with dignity
charlotte should be treated with respect
and dignity so should lindsay and there
should be an independent
uh review looking into these allegations
and that's certainly something he
supports and we believe should move
forward as quickly as possible
and meanwhile the new york attorney
general assistant james says well you
know the kind of independent
investigation that cuomo is talking
about not going to be good enough shows
the allegations of sexual harassment
should always be taken seriously there
must be a truly
independent investigation to thoroughly
review these troubling allegations
against the governor i stand ready to
oversee that investigation and make any
appointments necessary
so leticia james with her eye on that
gubernatorial seed meanwhile nancy
pelosi
she's now boxed in but the good news for
her is that andrew cuomo is no longer
useful so she put out a statement saying
the women who have come forward with
serious and credible charges against
governor cuomo deserve to be heard and
to be treated with dignity
the independence investigation must have
due process and respect for everyone
involved
funny because due process and respect
for everybody involved i'm that weirdly
that did not happen with brett kavanaugh
i'm old enough to remember that because
i'm more than three years old also
i i will say that i don't remember these
statements
about the necessity for due process and
a clear investigation
and everybody ought to be treated with
respect again when it came to joe biden
by the way where's kamal harrison all
this
remember when kamala harris the current
vice president of the united states said
about joe biden that he might want to
think about dropping out of the race
because of the terror read allegations
and then she was like oh i don't talk
about that anymore because i'm his vice
president
that's the way politics works this is
why just on a general level
when politicians try to sell you on the
idea that they are honest
they're self-interested okay sometimes
they're honest because it's in their
cell phone
their self-interest to be and some
politicians are more honest than others
they say things that are not in their
own self-interest the vast majority of
politicians
like everybody else on earth are
self-interested people who bend the
truth
okay this is why when politicians say
they have a harsh standard with regard
to x y or z
first you should check to see whether
they actually hold themselves to that
standard or who they hold to that
standard because usually the answer is
no there's just a double standard they
want a harsh standard for everybody else
and no standard for themselves
so it'll be interesting to see whether
the democratic party decides that the
android chrome was worth it
remember for a year they upheld him as
the pinnacle
of gubernatorial leadership while he was
apparently doing this stuff
they were allegedly doing this stuff
they held him up as the greatest
governor in america
it's amazing who they've held up as the
greatest governor in america in
california where the death rate per
million is about the same as in florida
except that california's garbage heap
that's been closed for an entire year
and florida has been wide open for
months gavin newsom another governor
being held up by the by the press and
the left is a wonderful governor
by the way california now leads the
nation in deaths from coven
um it turns out that gavin newsom was a
dining inside over the weekend in an
area where you're not allowed to dine
inside
how odd how odd the hypocrisy again the
standard does not apply
to the specials all pigs are equal
except for some of the pigs
here is uh here's gavin newsom dining
inside this isn't a tick tock george
tick tock actually how do i find out if
i can get a vaccination
george you got to go to my turn.ca.gov
wait a minute thank you governor
it's wonderful to be a surface george um
why are they inside that restaurant
they're not allowed to be that's in a
purple area
right it's an area where it's too it's
too much for the restaurant to be open
but there's gavin newsom inside the
restaurant this hypocrisy by the way
runs throughout american politics and
the hypocrisy again
i'm not a big fan of the charge of
hypocrisy unless the rule is bad
if the rule is bad then charges of
hypocrisy points out the stupidity of
the rule that's what hypocrisy charges
are designed to do
what people on the left like to do is
they will say things like look at this
religious person who went out and sinned
that means that the standard is bad we
should have no standards
well that's a stupid idea but if the
standard is bad like restaurants should
be closed
or the standard is bad like quote
unquote believe all women which is silly
because you should not believe all of
any group
human beings are human beings some are
telling the truth some are not okay then
then hypocrisy charges are perfectly
valuable
another another excellent example of
this over the weekend apparently
the berkeley unified union president a
guy named matt mayer is according to
reopen california schools
he's been leading efforts to keep
berkeley's schools closed for nearly a
year because it's unsafe
um he drops his kid off at a private
school for private in-person tutoring
for private in-person schooling isn't
that nice
right because that's the way this all
works the rules do not apply to the
people who are special
they never apply to the people who are
special which is one of the reasons
that donald trump was elected president
in 2016 right one of the reasons that
trump was elected president in 2016
is because he was a member of the
specials right donald trump is extremely
wealthy
donald trump is extremely famous and yet
here he was calling out the other
specials it was one of the reason for
his popularity
because when you have somebody who has
all of these things right when you have
somebody who is respected by the coterie
of the elite
and then he doesn't look down at other
americans this really was the pitch for
donald trump in 2016
and in 2020 he got in his own way a lot
but at heart that really was his pitch
all the way through it is the reason for
the maintaining popularity of donald
trump because the other story of the day
is that donald trump was speaking at
cpac over the weekend
there's a straw polled see pack these
straw polls are not typically useful
they've had straw polls in the past show
people like scott walker
winning the presidency of course that
never happened
very often ron paul would show up very
high in these straw polls even though he
really didn't
in the main polling but they tell you
something and the level of enthusiasm
for trump is still very high and as
as i've been saying for a while it is
not that people
are in love with everything trump right
this is something the left likes to say
is that if you are if you are supportive
of trump in any way or have been
supportive of trump in any way it's
because you buy
into all of his excesses or all the
things he said that are not true or you
like all of his behavior that's not
right
donald trump is just a giant fu to
everyone that's all donald trump is he's
a giant orange pulsating middle finger
that is what he and most republicans
know this most conservatives know this
right he is just a screw you now there
are some people who say you know what
it's not worth it for me to vote for
that guy
because you know the screw you isn't
important enough but there are a lot of
people for whom the screw you is very
important
because they look at the way that
politics is currently run and they say
donald trump pisses you guys off good we
like anything
that pisses you guys off because you
have created this little bubble for
yourselves
in which all of the elite gets to talk
to each other and cover for each other
and decide
who the rules apply to and who the rules
do not apply to and here's a guy the
rules
didn't apply to in nearly any way and
who has called you out for that
and so we kind of like that donald
trump's enduring popularity
it really is not because many
republicans think or
all republicans think that donald trump
would win the third time around
right it's not because people think that
donald trump is necessarily the best
republican candidate
right in fact the cpac straw poll showed
only 68 of people at cpac right which is
a very trumpy place want trump to run
again
the reason for trump's enduring support
is because people see
trump as a giant middle finger and
because they see him as a shield
who was kind of out there shielding them
from the blows or at least a magnet for
the blows that were originally
aimed at them or at least an avatar for
them and the fact that he was being
attacked because
really the people they wanted to attack
were the people standing behind trump
right all of the conservatives in
society those are the people that they
wanted to attack
okay so trump shows up at cpac over the
weekend
and he gave honestly what i thought was
a fairly good speech his
his speech contained a lot of things
that were good it contained
one particular jibe then of course the
media went nuts over it was designed to
do that he is a he is an
epic level troll he is a cave troll of
extraordinary proportions
so trump shows up in public to speak for
the first time since
he left office in january and uh he
began by attacking
joe biden and his his take on biden is
not wrong here gang he happens to be
correct about this
and by the way it's uh i think that
would behoove republicans
now it would be who republicans to take
a note from trump's playbook when it
comes to fighting biden's priorities
i know that they're focused on on
apparently other things
but the reality is the stuff that
actually matters in american life
i know a lot of republicans right now
are focused in on the 1.9 trillion
dollar stimulus package that's all fine
and good
and the 1.9 still trillion dollar
stimulus package is a joke
it only a small percentage of that money
actually goes to americans
even though i think frankly a lot of
that is even unnecessary given the fact
that there are a lot of states that are
wide open right now
even of the 1.9 trillion dollar package
if you think that a lot of that should
go to americans most of it is not
the vast majority of it is not but the
focus for republicans right now
should really not be on the taxing and
spending it should be on the overall
move
by the joe biden administration to
enshrine the idea that america is
stomachacy racist
is systemically sexist is systemically
evil and needs to be
remolded from the inside and donald
trump
speaks out about that in a way that many
other republicans seem afraid to
particularly mainstream republicans
okay the the the real political battle
of our time
is not a battle over spending it isn't
okay
i think spending is super important i do
i thought it was really important donald
trump was doing it as president of the
united states
but for most americans they don't
inherently care all that much about the
national debt it's just a political
baton anytime the other party's in power
you care about the national debt anytime
your own party is in power you just
ignore the national debt some of us are
consistent and don't like the national
debt
being increased under any president but
the real battle that people feel in
their bones right now
is the culture war that is going on in
which half the country has declared the
other half of the country
deplorable and evil and wrong-headed and
fascistic
and donald trump is speaking up for a
lot of those americans in a way that
other republicans are not somebody could
fill that vacuum
where are the other republicans filling
that vacuum until somebody else
on the right fills that vacuum it's
going to be very difficult for donald
trump to go away
okay even if you like trump and you want
to see him just you know move off to the
side and continue to wage his political
battles but you don't want to see him
run again
or you'd like to see a new face uh maybe
a maybe a less damaged face
for a lot of that agenda somebody is
gonna have to step up and fill that role
as the person who goes to battle in the
culture wars that means you can't ignore
the culture war issues the irony of
course is that donald trump
is the most oddly placed person to fight
these culture war issues considering the
guy is kind of socially liberal on a lot
of things except for abortion
and yet it's donald trump who has stood
up repeatedly and said common sensical
stuff about this sort of thing
it's the reason for his popularity so
where's the republican who's going to
step in and pick up that baton
until that happens he's going to
maintain his durability as a member
of the of the uh sort of center of
republican politics
so here is a bit of trump's speech the
trump was speaking cpac of course
and uh and he went after biden he said
biden had a horrible first month
joe biden has had the most disastrous
first month of any president
in modern history that's true
already the biden administration has
proven
that they are anti-jobs anti-family
anti-borders anti-energy
anti-women and anti-science
in just one short month we have gone
from
america first to america last
okay this sort of attack line is one
that republicans need to be making
it happens to be true i know that the
media have tried to make joe biden into
a genial
older fellow who's filled with empathy
his policies as we've been pointing out
every day on the show are
extraordinarily radical
more radical than the obama
administration's policies his take on
the world that has been promulgated
via his administration which is that
equity meaning
anti-racism impromex candy nonsense is
it the center of all of his policies
that stuff is extremely radical but on
the right everybody is focused in on hey
look a stimulus bill that's too much
money i agree it's too much money
and i agree you should do your best in
congress to stop it also where is the
leadership
calling out the actual battle for the
soul of the country which is what does
this
what should the motivating ideology of
the country be
here was trump touching an issue that
many republicans seem afraid to touch
publicly
and that of course is the issue of trans
policies being pushed by the biden
administration
here he was going after the equality the
so-called equality act the orwellian
equality act which suggests that men
ought to compete alongside women
a less equal idea it's hard to imagine
here was trump going after that
joe biden and the democrats are even
pushing policies that would destroy
women's sports young girls and women are
in sense
that they are now being forced to
compete against those who are
biological males it's not good for
women it's not good for women's sports
which worked so long and so hard to get
to where they are
the records that stood for years even
decades are now being smashed with ease
smashed if this has not changed
women's sports as we know it will die
they'll end it'll end okay so the left
makes fun of this sort of stuff like why
does this matter why did it because
the redefinition of basic biological sex
matters
pretending that everybody is exactly the
same in all respects and thus
all outcomes ought to be exactly the
same because everybody of course is
exactly the same
is a recipe for top down control it is a
recipe for disaster
that's why this stuff actually matters
and yes americans care about this sort
of stuff
by the way if you think that it ends at
women's athletics you are dead wrong it
doesn't end at women's athletics it ends
with children being taken out of homes
if parents refuse to go along with the
prevailing views of their public school
their kid should have a sex change
okay that's where this is going to end
eventually you already see this kind of
stuff happening
in certain parts of canada by the way
he's already seen threats to
to parental conservatorship based on
refusal to acknowledge
that your child is actually a member of
the gender that they say they are a
member of
rather than their actual biological sex
this is not the last step here
right trump was in essence a culture war
figure he continues to be a culture war
figure and until somebody on the right
picks up that mantle there's not gonna
be any belts on the right picking up
that mantle we all know it
okay so the left likes to make this all
about you know trump and people
people love trump because trump says all
these terrible things and all of these
tweets that
a lot of people don't like and because
trump was telling lies after the
election about the
that is not why people like trump they
the answer if you ask conservatives
if you ask republicans why they are
still warm to trump the answer is they
would rather have the guy who's punching
back
even if he is punching back in dirty and
wrong ways than the person who sits
there and just takes it
right this is why you get to why he but
he fights stuff from conservatives now
i've always made the case with trump
that but he fights has to come with an
asterisk which is if you keep punching
yourself in your own face
that's not a good way of fighting yes
it's good that he fights
it's also bad that he fought in such a
way that he lost to an actual corpse in
joe biden
if there's a way to fight in which you
win but if you ask republicans which
would i prefer
the one who fights or the one who
doesn't fight because both are not gonna
win victory but i'd rather have the one
who fights
that is what you're gonna end up with
okay trump also went after biden on the
teachers unions
again this this happens to be correct
stuff
there's no reason whatsoever why the
vast majority of young americans
should not be back in school immediately
the only reason that most parents do not
have that choice
is because joe biden sold out america's
children
to the teachers unions his position is
morally inexcusable you know that
joe biden has shamefully betrayed
america's youth
and he is cruelly keeping our children
locked in their homes no reason for it
whatsoever they want to get out
they're cheating the next generation of
americans
out of the future that they deserve and
they do deserve this future they're
going to grow up
and they're going to have a scar okay by
the way all of it's true
all of that is true joe biden is
enthralled to the teachers unions
everybody knows it even the new york
times has a piece today titled as school
closures in your first anniversary a
diverse parent movement demands action
now
normally the way they push this is
democratic policies on school closings
push republican
kickback right the republicans pounce on
school closings okay but even the new
york times is being forced to recognize
that these school closings
have no basis in reality that schools
being closed
are not a good answer to what has been
happening with coveted particularly as
the vaccines get rolled out faster and
faster they have a long piece in the new
york times today
all about a all about a diverse
body of people in philadelphia of all
places who are saying we need to reopen
these schools
a queen tyler a mother and hair stylist
in north philadelphia has been
disappointed in her neighborhood's
public schools for many years
now her nine-year-old son and
13-year-old daughter have been learning
online for nearly a year
even as masked children gather
boisterously at local private schools
miss tyler is planning a radical change
moving her family to florida
where the republican controlled state
government has mandated that all
districts provide in-person learning
five days a week
a niece there is attending traditional
public school in sarasota complete with
sports
art and music okay well welcome down
here
leave your politics at home seriously
you bring a bunch of democrat crap down
here and you make it
worse then uh please stay in
philadelphia
but if you want to come down here and be
part of a free state i just moved her to
be part of a free state
then come on down the water's fine
again trump's push back here has some
there is such a base for republican
victory here
now people are writing off the
republican party because what happened
on january 6 which was truly an awful
egregious and evil incident by
a fringe group of people who broke off
even from a bigger rally
yeah they're people who are writing off
the republican party because of supposed
conflict inside the corridors of the
republican party
here's the point when there is a point
of pushback that unifies the republican
party
they could easily win back the house
they could easily win back the senate
and they could win back the presidency
in 2024 this is not a pipe dream
okay if you had said to people in 1976
after gerald ford
lost to jimmy carter in the aftermath of
watergate how long it would take for
republicans to get back into power
people probably would have said about 15
20 years instead it was four
things turn real fast because bad policy
has consequences
in just a second we're gonna get to more
of bad policy here
and uh and we'll talk about trump's
trollish comment that he's gonna run for
a third time will he actually do so
we'll get to that in just one moment
first
let's talk about the fact that going to
an auto parts store really not something
that you're up for like you're really
not up for it i mean why would you be
why would you want to stand in line
and then you get to the front of the
line and then the person asks you for a
specific part you have no idea
finally you figure it out they order it
online or you could just stay at home
and order it online and then we'll come
to your door you won't have to wait in
line you're gonna have to get the up
charge
over at the store this is why you need
rockauto.com rockauto.com they always
offer the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts like let's say
hypothetically you haven't needed a
delphi fg1456 fuel pump assembly for a
2005 to 2010 honda odyssey that'll cost
you like 354 bucks
at a big chain store well rockauto.com
that costs you 217 bucks that's a lot of
money
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
you're gonna save all sorts of quan when
you head over to rockauto.com their
catalog is unique remarkably easy to
navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices that you
prefer
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need
rockauto.com right shapiro in there how
did you hear about usbox so they know
that we sent you rockauto.com go check
them out
right now okay in just one second we're
going to get to
the future of trump personally inside
the republican party
and again another example of left over
its skis when it comes to trying to
cancel cancel folks
first there's so many narratives around
hot topic issues it's hard to keep track
of all the newest controversies
the left decides to be offended by on
any given day
like for example now they're trying to
cancel dr seuss they say dr seuss is
racist look
it can be difficult to respond to a lot
of these ridiculous quote unquote
arguments they're not real arguments
they're just emotional appeals
a lot of the time it might mean doing
your own research and diving into the
data that can be super time consuming
that is why we at the daily wire have
launched a brand new series it's just
for our members it is called
debunked it's a new show i'm hosting
every friday the point of the series
is to provide you with a breakdown of
popular fallacies purported
pushed by the political left i've done
the research i know the data i walk you
through it in 15 minutes or less
on a different topic every week it is
super useful it is only for our members
last friday's episode covered minimum
wage i'm sure you've heard the argument
before we need a livable minimum wage
what liberal activists and politicians
want to acknowledge however is that the
minimum wage
was generally not designed to be livable
it actually pushes people out of work
because the minimum wage is zero for all
the people who end up unemployed
debunked
is available exclusively to daily wire
members head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off your new membership that is code
debunked is a great resource plus you're
getting all the other great stuff you
get to be part of all access you get
access to our new gina carano movie that
we're working on right now
you get access to run hide fight we have
a brand new show coming out with candace
zones we have tons of stuff that you are
going to love
go check us out at dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked right now to
get 25
off your brand new membership and get
access to this special show it's gonna
give you all the resources you need
to fight with all the people you
disagree with go watch the minimum wage
episode stay tuned we have a new topic
this friday
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
so if only seeking to prove the right's
point about trump
right the left has decided that
basically everything must be canceled
everything is racist and here's the
thing
it's like the incredibles right if
everybody is special nobody's special if
everybody is canceled nobody is canceled
if you don't actually go after people
who you think deserve to be canceled
on the basis of very specific behavior
you just go after everyone
you start to get ignored you're the boy
who cried cancel and this is what the
left has become
they've become the person of unspecified
gender identity
who calls cancel that's what they are
and so we don't pay attention to you
anymore
this is a problem it's a problem for the
right it's a problem for the left
because the truth is there are certain
things that
we all find kind of gross we don't want
people saying
and there are social strictures to those
things but as a general rule the left
wants everybody they don't like canceled
and not just people they don't like for
like a great reason
not like neo-nazis they'll just label
everybody a white supremacist or a
neo-nazi
and this of course is what has driven so
many republicans to support for
people like president trump because he
is the loudest and he is the most out
there
and he is the person who's taken the
most hits and so people on the right now
associate takes the most hits
with the person who tells the truth the
most because those two things tend to be
pretty highly correlated where the left
is concerned
if you see the people the left likes to
attack the most very often it's the
people who are saying the most things
now the problem is sometimes it's not
right sometimes the left is attacking
margaery taylor
great example sometimes the left is
attacking mars retailer green for jewish
space lasers
seems like a good pretty good reason to
go after somebody they believe the
jewish space lasers started a california
wildfire
or they are touting the q on theory but
the exact same level of outrage met
marjorie taylor green
saying that there are two genders which
is true as her saying that there are
jewish space lasers which is crazy
so at a certain point the righteous says
we don't trust anything you people have
to say
to say it's why there is so much
skepticism of the institutional media
it's why there's so much skepticism
of the left when they make claims people
are not evaluating claim by claim
whether the left is telling the truth
instead they're just ignoring the left
wholesale and the left
just keeps on doing it i mean it's truly
incredible
so for example alyssa milano is now
pushing a weird theory okay so cpac's
stage
was built in a certain way okay and
usually it is kind of the hotel planner
who decides how the
the stage is going to be set up
particularly at a place like the hyatt
alyssa milano put out a graphic
of sort of an aerial view of the stage
and she said
this is a nazi symbol she said this is
the stage at cpac
they're not even trying to hide it
anymore hyatt this is what's happening
in your building
ted cruz you stood on this stage
and she says that that stage was built
in order to resemble a nazi symbol okay
you're a crazy person
i'm sorry you're totally wild you're
wild and crazy this is no less crazy
than the q and on crap
if you think that people at cpac and
matt schlapp was like you know what we
need a stage let's make it in the shape
of a giant swastika
hmm nobody'll catch on to whom are you
signaling
alyssa milano you caught onto the code
alyssa but these people like
alyssa milano who dressed up in like a
handmaid's tale outfit to go to justice
kavanaugh hearings
like that person is considered a serious
human on the left
people are considered serious for
calling on the hyatt to be boycotted
because they hosted cpac
by the way good for hyatt hayek came out
and they're like you know what we host
all sorts of conferences go aft yourself
this by the way should be the response
of every single corporation in america
when the wokes come for them
according to fox 26 houston hyatt hotels
defended its decision to host
the 2021 conservative political action
conference at a time when the political
climate has become
increasingly volatile citing its belief
that individuals and organizations
should be able to peacefully gather and
express their own views the three-day
event is being held at the hyatt regency
orlando in florida featuring a slew of
prominent republican speakers from
lawmakers and former administrations
uh former administration officials to
president trump
the spokesperson for hyatt said quote we
take pride in operating
a highly inclusive environment we
believe that the facilitation of
gatherings is a central element of what
we do as a hospitality company
we believe in the right of individuals
and organizations to peacefully express
their views
independent of the degree to which the
perspectives of those hosting meetings
and events in our hotels align with ours
our own values support a culture that is
characterized by empathy respect and
diversity of opinions and backgrounds we
strive to bring this to light through
what we do
and how we engage with those in our care
and this of course
prompted boycott hyatt to trend on
social media
this is how you got trump gang you're
gonna keep getting it good and hard
this is how this is how the right is
going to continue pushing into the
culture wars the harder you push
the harder the backlash is going to be
and by the way they are pushing
unbelievably hard
the scariest story of the last couple of
weeks is amazon coming after books
i mean digital book burnings are now a
real thing
according to the daily wire amanda
presta giacomo reporting
conservatives are sounding the alarm
about an updated amazon policy that bans
books
the ubiquitous billion dollar company
deems offensive or includes so-called
hate speech
as noted by daily wire amazon has ramped
up its censorship on conservative views
in recent weeks for example
a popular documentary on u.s supreme
court justice clarence thomas was banned
from their streaming service this past
week
before that move the company
deplatformed conservative ryan
anderson's book
critical of gender theory when harry
became sally when just the news reached
out to amazon over at a ban on
anderson's book
the outlet directed them to a page
outlining
their content guidelines for books under
a section labeled defensive content
amazon now states they quote don't sell
certain content including contact we
determine is hate speech
promotes the abuse or sexual
exploitation of children okay so i'm
just going to point out
that you have literally have books
promoting the sexual abuse and
exploitation of children
when you are telling five-year-olds that
they can be members of the opposite sex
and that they might want to get puberty
blockers that is the sexual abuse and
exploitation of children end of story
they say they don't sell certain content
involving content they determine is hate
speech
so if you say that that's bad by the way
that's hate speech contains pornography
glorifies rape or pedophilia advocates
terrorism
or other material would deem
inappropriate or offensive
the report says the review of those
policies suggests that sometime in the
last few months
amazon made a major change to the ways
in which it moderates book content on
its servers
imposing a much stricter standard on
books than it had previously done
it appears the company recently added
so-called hate speech to their
guidelines on book platforming and is
amping up their censorship
of the quote unquote offensive this is
going to lead to the complete
cancellation and banning
of conservative books entirely we
already saw them try to do this with
abigail
schreier's book abigail schreier points
out when a company controls over 83
percent of the market for books
it begins the process of deleting ideas
from a society
a bookseller can sell what it wants if
marxist books wants to only sell books
that conform to its ideology okay that
has integrity but this is the world's
largest bookseller
amazon can basically make books
disappear for all readers
and does so on a blatantly dishonest
basis
my understanding by the way is that even
if you bought these books
they may have erased them from your
kindle so it doesn't matter if you
already bought the book
like if you have hair when harry became
sally on amazon like you bought it
on the kindle version i believe they've
disappeared it from the kindle somebody
can correct me if i'm wrong
okay this sort of stuff is what
americans are afraid of and they should
be afraid of it because it has infused
all of our society according to ash
scale
boston public schools have suspended
advanced class enrollment tests
right they've decided they're no longer
going to allow you to
enter admission tests and new
enrollments
okay why well because they're afraid
that the people who are doing well on
the test are too white and too asian
and asians of course are not a minority
when they perform well then they're just
white people
according to ash scale new fifth and
sixth graders will not be accepted into
advanced classes in boston the entire
city
for the next year the entry test was
suspended due to the pandemic while at
the same time the school district has
raised concerns about racial equity
problems
noting that a vast majority of students
in those classes are white or asian
gbh news reported the selective program
called advanced work classes will
suspend enrollment because of the
pandemic but also they cited concerns
about equity
because more than 70 percent of students
enrolled in the program were white and
asian even though 80 percent
of boston public school students are
hispanic and black superintendent brenda
casilia said
there's been a lot of inequities they've
been brought to light in the pandemic
there's a lot of work we have to do to
be anti-racist there it is your code
word
anti-racist it's the infusion of this
bull crap throughout all of american
culture
and you will be canceled if you disagree
and your children will be denied
opportunity if you disagree and then
when you flee to a private school they
will follow you there see here's the
thing there are no
places where you get to live your life
the left has determined that all of
society is to be their safe space
it'd be one thing for them to say okay
we just want our safe space even in this
little domain on campus
then they declared all of campus is our
safe space then they declared all of
corporate america is our safe space then
they declared
your church is our safe space they will
soon declare that your home must also be
their safe space
all of society must be their safe space
because in order for them to live
their most fulfilled expressive lives as
we talked about last week
you have to acknowledge and cheer them
it is not enough
for you to just say live your life and
leave me alone that is not enough you
must accept
and cheer them because you see your
failure to cheer is an imposition on
their personal happiness
you are the problem it's not their
failure to conform to societal standards
which we all have to do from time to
time in ways we don't particularly like
is that the left believes all of society
must conform to them and particularly
you
must conform to them in every available
way and so they've taken over every
institution
every major institution of our society
uh it's hard to think of a more symbolic
a more symbolic move than the one that
was just made in the entertainment
industry
by dc comics so apparently according to
observer.com
shadow and act has has a scoop author
tana haasi coates is now writing a
superman feature film produced by jj
abrams
as of now the project is shrouded in
mystery with no information provided on
whether the movie will be a sequel to
man of steel
or complete reboot without henry cavill
deadline says the film is a reboot
there's no director attached no plot
details available
code said to be invited into the dc
extended universe by warner brothers dc
films and bad robot is an honor i look
forward to meaningfully adding to the
legacy of america's most iconic
mythic hero he's listed in the thank you
credits of avengers infinity war end
game and black panther of course because
he penned some black panther
and captain america comic books in which
captain america gets woke
toby emmerich the warner brothers
chairman said his best-selling novel
between the world and me is
it's a non-fiction book lends itself to
a new and exciting way of viewing
the man of steel if by new and exciting
you mean that the guy
who used to be iconic for saying truth
justice in the american way
will now be systemic racism evil in the
american way
i mean this is what's going to happen
right you've taken
a superhero whose literal pitch is that
america is good and he is defending
american values
you're taking that and you're handing
that over to a guy who literally said
that he was watching 911 happen from the
top of an apartment building while
smoking marijuana i believe this is in
his memoir
and he suggested that he felt nothing
because of
the long history of racism in america
that's the person you're having superman
over to
now again it's a private company
but they are wrecking a piece of
intellectual property
that was designed to be pro-america by
handing it to a person who really does
not like the foundational ideals of this
country
ta-nehisi coates is not a fan of the
foundational ideals of the country
he like nicole hannah jones believes
they were a lie when written he believes
they have never been truly acted out
and he believes that the fundamental
ideals of the country have to
fundamentally shift
tanahasi coates is a is a a
slightly more soft-spoken ibrahim in
terms of his actual politics
he is more social basically his idea is
that we need socialism in order to cure
racism he's kind of a bernie sanders
acolyte
along these lines but he's a racial
essentialist
he believes that that black and white
cannot understand each other
and you are handing superman the most
iconic american piece of intellectual
property there is
over the ta-nehisi codes so every
instant
every part of our culture is now being
militarized
on behalf of the woke left and then you
wonder why there is a blowback
there will be a blowback and will be
egregious
final mode on this we've been updating
you on the
hubbub surrounding the bachelor you
remember that bachelor host chris
harrison who's the host for like the
last 25 years
has been replaced over the last 20 years
he's been replaced
temporarily right and he was replaced
because he had the temerity to say
that a contestant was originally
defended by the first black bachelor
because he was dating her
as not racist harrison said maybe we
should give her some grace and now he's
been canceled
from a show on which he's an executive
producer well now
now he has been replaced in the final on
the
beyond the rose episode whatever the
hell that is by a person named emmanuel
akko who hosts a youtube series about
confronting racism
for the bachelor after the final rose
akko the host of the youtube series
uncomfortable conversations with the
black man announced on saturday he would
host the one-hour special for the 25th
season
and akka will address the situation
head-on during the special because
clearly a dating show requires a person
who is a specialist in confronting
racism on youtube
sounds fantastic apparently the show has
placed a disclaimer on scene's films
before harrison
stepped aside the wrap reports that last
week's episode which featured footage of
harrison competing
on a celebrity edition of wheel of
fortune noted the scenes were filmed in
december we have to make sure that
everybody knows
that chris harrison has been canceled
and any appearance by chris harrison is
an appearance from the past
every institution every institution will
be militarized on behalf
of the woke left and you're either a
tool or an obstacle to them unless you
push back
hence the enduring popularity of donald
trump who is more of an obstacle
to the left than anybody else apparently
right this is the way that the left
views it alrighty we'll have another
hour of the program a little bit later
today in the meantime go check out the
michael knowles show
michael will be talking about trump at
cpac that episode is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavo wiedowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
former president trump dominates cpac
democrats appear to turn on new york
governor andrew cuomo as another woman
accuses him of sexual harassment and a
famous priest
doesn't respect god's preferred pronouns
check it out on the michael knowles show